Welcome to the deep dive.
This is where we take a whole
stack of different sources,
articles, sometimes research
papers, our own notes, and we
really try to boil it all down.
We pull up the key insights, the
core ideas, basically giving you
a shortcut to being genuinely
well informed on a topic.
Quickly but thoroughly.
Exactly.
And hopefully with enough, you
know, surprising details and
just genuine curiosity to keep
you listening.
Absolutely.
So today we're diving into
something I think is really
fascinating It it challenges a
perception that's probably
pretty deep seated for a lot of
us about, well, one of
histories, most recognizable
figures.
Think about how we usually
picture Jesus.
For many, myself included,
sometimes it's this kind of
simplified, almost invincible
image, right?
Right, the standard picture.
Yeah, the Superman and Sandals
idea, someone called it.
You know, untouchable.
Kind of floating above the
messiness of being human.
Yeah, effortlessly dropping
miracles like party favors.
Yeah, that phrase really
captures it.
And this perception, one of our
main sources, points out it
often comes from, well, bits and
pieces.
Pop Catholicism.
Cultural shorthand?
Maybe the occasional Easter
homily?
Christmas pageants.
Oh, definitely.
Christmas pageants, stained
glass windows, those old movies
where Jesus looks like this
glowing Englishman who never
even breaks a sweat.
Right.
Very serene.
Very otherworldly.
And there's a comfort in that,
isn't there?
Imagining this all powerful,
completely unassailable divine
being.
It feels safe.
It absolutely does.
It provides a certain security
of familiarity.
And those cultural narratives,
they're incredibly potent,
visually appealing, easy to
grasp.
Sure.
But, and this is the crucial
part, what's really profound is
how those very idealized images,
while comforting, can sometimes
maybe inadvertently hide A much
deeper truth, a more challenging
one, maybe a truth about
vulnerability and about the the
really interactive nature of
spiritual power.
This common picture can
sometimes feel like God.
Just, you know, cosplaying as a
man.
Cosplaying a man Wow.
Yeah, implying there wasn't a
genuine human experience there,
no real dependence on anything
outside himself.
It kind of bypasses the raw,
unfiltered reality that our
sources for today really bring
to light.
And honestly, that reality makes
the story even more compelling.
And that profound reality,
that's exactly what we're
digging into today.
Our deep dive is going to center
on one specific moment from the
Gospels.
It's often overlooked, actually.
But for the author of this
contemporary reflection we're
using, it was the moment that
really quote broke him open.
It radically shifted his view.
Which moment is that?
It's Jesus's return to his
hometown Nazareth, a scene that
reveals, well, a far more human,
far more relational, and far
more vulnerable Jesus than maybe
we're used to seeing.
Nazareth.
Yes, that's a powerful one.
Really cuts against the grain of
the usual miracle story.
Exactly.
So yeah, to unpack this, this
pivotal moment, we'll be looking
mainly at the accounts in
Matthew, Mark and Luke, the
synoptic gospels, right?
And we're pairing those with
this really insightful modern
reflection you mentioned.
But it helps bring a fresh
perspective to these ancient
texts, kind of pulls back the
curtain on the side of Jesus
that, well, it often gets
overshadowed.
Yeah, definitely.
So our mission today is to
really get into this rarely
discussed story, understand what
it might be saying about the
nature of power, the nature of
faith, and ultimately figure out
what it might mean for you
listening right now in your own
life.
OK, let's unpack this then let's
try and put ourselves right
there.
Picture the scene.
We're in Nazareth inside the
synagogue, and it's crucial to
remember this isn't just any
town.
This is his hometown.
Jesus is coming to his hometown
and teaching the people in their
synagogue.
The intimacy is key.
Absolutely.
These aren't strangers who've
just heard rumors.
These are the folks he grew up
with.
Try and visualize it.
You know, the men he might have
learned carpentry alongside.
Haggling over wood prices.
Exactly.
The women who watched him grow
up maybe shared knowing looks
with Mary, the kids he played
with who knew him just as Joseph
and Mary's boy.
You know the kid down the
street.
This is his community, his
childhood, his roots.
It's that small town vibe where
everybody thinks they know
everything about everyone else
and they definitely think they
know him.
You've hit on something really
critical there.
There's always a tension, isn't
there?
When someone achieves something
notable and then goes back home,
Oh yeah, but for a profit, it's
amplified.
There's this whole lifetime of
shared history, mundane
interactions, just everyday
stuff.
And that crease sees really deep
seated expectations.
Right, they have a box for him
already.
Exactly.
They knew she's the kid, she's
the young Craftsman working with
his dad, just part of the local
scene.
So when he comes back now as
this charismatic teacher, maybe
rumors of miracles swirling.
It directly challenges their
fixed ideas about him.
And it implicitly challenges the
town's social structure, too.
This deep familiarity is ironic.
It could have been a source of
pride.
Like hey look, one of ours made
good.
Yeah, you'd think so.
Or, as we're about to see, it
can become this huge, almost
like insurmountable wall, a
barrier to actually accepting
his new authority, his true
identity.
You can almost feel the mix in
that synagogue, can't you?
A bit of curiosity, maybe.
Sure, a little buzz, maybe some
hometown pride initially.
But then quickly, it shifts.
Suspicion creeps in.
Skepticism, maybe even a little
resentment.
Like who does he think he is
that possessiveness over their
local boy who dared to be
something more?
That human tendency to keep
people in their boxes precisely
and Matthews account, which is
one of our main gospel sources
here, it captures this dynamic
just perfectly.
The first reaction are modern
source notes.
It is amazement.
Right.
They hear him teach.
Yeah, they're hearing this guy,
the one they knew from forever,
speak with this incredible
wisdom.
Maybe they've heard whispers
about things he's done
elsewhere.
But that amazement, it almost
instantly starts to curdle.
It turns sour fast.
It really does.
It morphs into these pointed
questions, and they don't sound
like genuine inquiries.
You know, they sound like
defensive skepticism, almost an
accusation.
Like they're cross examining.
Him.
Exactly where did this man get
this wisdom in these miraculous
powers?
It's less about understanding,
more about challenging his right
to have them.
Undermining his legitimacy.
Totally.
And then comes the kicker, the
dismissive familiarity, the
thing that really pulls the rug
out from under his authority.
Isn't this the carpenter's son?
Isn't his mother's name Mary?
And aren't his brothers James,
Joseph, Simon and Judas?
Aren't all his sisters with us?
Where then did this man get all
these things?
Listing the whole family,
basically saying we know you're
folks, you're one of us, don't
get too big for your boots.
Right, and the text says they
took offense at him.
It's that classic small town
thing, isn't it?
Who does this guy think he is
coming back here acting all
important?
We changed his diapers.
Or, you know, the ancient
equivalent.
And if we connect us to the
bigger picture, that progression
from amazement to offense, it's
absolutely critical.
It reveals this deep human
resistance, resistance to
change, resistance to letting
people outgrow the roles we've
assigned them.
They go from that initial
flicker of wonder, maybe even
awe, straight to suspicion, and
then ultimately to this visceral
rejection.
And it's based entirely on their
prior knowledge.
They're intimate and, crucially,
their fixed idea of who he was.
Right.
It's not about what he's saying
or doing.
Exactly.
It's the classic, we know who
you really are.
You're just like us, you can't
possibly be anything more.
That phenomenon and mentioning
the specific family members,
Mary, the brothers and sisters.
And so that's not just adding
color.
It highlights just how deeply
personal, how rooted this
disbelief was.
Yeah, it wasn't abstract
theology for them.
Not at all.
It wasn't about the content of
his teaching, which Matthew
implies was amazing.
It wasn't about evidence of
miracles, it was purely about
his perceived identity, an
identity that just didn't fit
their mental box for him.
And Jesus's response as Matthew
records it, it's so poignant.
It's not really a complaint,
more like a sad observation,
almost a lament, right?
What does he say again?
A prophet is not without honor
except in his own town and in
his own home.
Yeah, it's not him whining about
her pride.
It's him recognizing this
universal human thing, a
tendency that, let's be honest,
still happens today.
We often undervalue or dismiss
or just fail to see the
potential of those closest to
us.
We're too familiar.
We think we already know them.
Yeah, familiarity breeds
contempt, or at least blindness
sometimes.
Exactly.
Blindness to transformation.
And here's where it gets really
stark.
This is where that Superman and
Sandals image just starts to
crack wide open.
Matthew's account gives us the
consequence of this rejection,
and it's a line that just hangs
in the air.
And he did not do many miracles
there because of their lack of
faith.
Notice that phrasing.
It doesn't say he chose not to,
or that he withheld his power to
punish them.
It says he did not do them.
Which really suggests A
limitation, doesn't it?
A constraint that's directly
tied to their belief, or more
accurately, their profound lack
of belief.
It's like their disbelief acted
as a kind of dampener, a
spiritual short circuit.
Yeah, that's a good way to put.
It this is absolutely the first
major crack in that idealized
image of, you know, effortless,
independent omnipotence.
It fundamentally suggests that
his power, or at least how it
manifested, wasn't just this
internal switch He could flip
anytime, anywhere, regardless of
the situation.
Right.
It wasn't operating in a vacuum.
Exactly.
It introduces this profoundly
relational dynamic power working
in relation to the people
present.
It wasn't about Jesus punishing
them, like you said, it feels
more like a direct consequence,
almost like a law of spiritual
physics was at play.
Spiritual physics, Yeah.
Interesting.
Yeah, like the very atmosphere
in that room, saturated with
their collective disbelief,
their cynicism.
It created this, this barrier.
Yeah, maybe an impenetrable 1.
He simply couldn't operate in
the way he did elsewhere.
And that's not about weakness in
him.
It's a revelation about the
nature of the power itself, how
it works.
Wow.
OK, And Mark's account, our
second gospel source here.
It just drives this point home
even more bluntly.
It strips away any possible
ambiguity.
Matthew says he did not do many
miracles, but Mark states it
with this like undeniable,
almost shocking force.
He says he could not do any
miracles there except lay his
hands on a few sick people and
heal them, and then adds he was
amazed at their lack of faith.
OK, let's really zero in on that
phrase.
He could not the original Greek
verb.
There you get dunato.
It translates very directly.
It means he was not able.
It signifies an actual
inability, not just an
unwillingness.
It's huge.
Because it contrasts sharply
with other times in the gospels
where Jesus maybe chooses not to
do miracle, perhaps because
people are just demanding a sign
or something like.
That right, testing him.
Exactly.
But here Mark presents it as an
inherent limitation 1 imposed by
the external environment, the
collective disbelief of the
crowd, that pervasive skepticism
in the synagogue he occurred in,
an actual palpable barrier his
power couldn't fully manifest.
It's really profound when you
sit with it.
Yeah, it really is.
Could not.
And just as significant is that
detail Mark includes, Jesus was
amazed at their lack of faith.
Right.
Even he was surprised.
Apparently, this wasn't an
expected outcome for him.
It wasn't just a hurdle he saw
coming and easily overcame.
It was something that genuinely
astonished him.
Maybe even, you know,
disappointed him deeply.
It affected him, and the fact
that he could still manage to
lay hands on a few sick people
and heal them, that actually
highlights the contrast even
more starkly.
Doesn't.
It how so?
Well, it shows the severe
limitation on his power in that
specific faithless air, as one
source puts it.
It's like imagine a tiny spark
desperately trying to catch fire
in a room with almost no oxygen.
OK, maybe in a few isolated
pockets where a tiny bit of
belief or simple human needs
still existed, a flicker of
healing was possible.
But the overall atmosphere?
It was suffocating the flame.
You're trying to turn on a light
switch when the whole circuit
board is dead.
Exactly.
Or trying to charge a battery in
an environment that actively
drains the power faster than it
can come in.
The few individual connections
where maybe some faith still
existed allowed for a minimal
transfer of healing, but the
overall atmosphere was just
completely prohibitive.
Wow, OK, so Matthew says did
not, Marxist could not.
And then Luke's account, our
third source, adds this really
disturbing, violent twist.
Yeah, Lewd escalates it
dramatically.
It goes way beyond just offense
or disbelief.
It turns into outright
hostility, act of aggression,
Luke writes.
All the people in the synagogue
were furious when they heard
this.
They got up, drove him out of
the town, and took him to the
brow of the hill on which the
town was built in order to throw
him off the Cliff.
I mean, just pause there.
Fury Attempted murder over words
spoken in a synagogue by someone
they knew.
It's shocking.
It's an absolutely terrifying
escalation from skepticism to
fury to attempted lynching.
It just reveals the visceral
threat they felt.
His presence, his claims, his
challenging other expectations.
It wasn't just ignored, it was
perceived as such a profound
danger to their whole worldview.
To their understanding of God,
maybe.
Yes, and of prophecy and maybe
just their comfortable small
town reality.
It provoked this murderous rage.
This isn't just about a prophet
being dismissed politely.
This is a community so deeply
invested in their static picture
of him, Joseph's boy, that
they'd rather kill him than let
him challenge that picture or
redefine who they thought he
was.
It's.
Intense, but then Luke adds that
other little.
Detail.
Yes, the ending, but he walked
right through the crowd and went
on his way.
Right.
What do you make of that?
Well, it's brief but powerful,
isn't it?
It's this camera moment.
It shows the kind of momentary
contained power, a sort of
transcendent common control,
even right in the middle of this
murderous mob.
Yeah, not like a big flashy
miracle.
No, not a pillar of fire or
anything.
More like a quiet, almost
surgical exercise of personal
authority enough to simply
remove himself from a situation
that was clearly spiritually
buried, barren, and physically
dangerous.
He didn't engage the violence
didn't overpower them.
He just walked through and then
wisely chose to leave.
So this whole Nazareth incident,
it really is, as our source
says, the moment nobody talks
about, isn't it?
I don't think it's glossed over.
Yeah, when we think of Jesus,
it's usually The Walking on
water, the feeding, the 5000,
raising Lazarus, the big
triumphant moment.
A highlight reel.
Exactly.
But this scene?
This is Jesus, the Son of God,
standing in his childhood
synagogue, getting heckled,
dismissed and then facing a
lynch mob by the people he grew
up with.
And crucially, in the face of
their collective disbelief, the
Gospels tell us his power was
limited.
You could not do many miracles
there.
It shatters the simple image.
Completely.
Our contemporary source puts it
so powerfully.
The room itself, the very
environment created by their
disbelief, literally made him
powerless.
The faithless air choked the
miracles like oxygen sucked out
of a flame.
And here's where our
understanding really has to
shift, doesn't it?
It is something far more
nuanced, and maybe, in a strange
way, more relatable.
Because this is not the
triumphant, untouchable miracle
worker we usually imagine.
This is Jesus, Son of God, yes,
but also facing raw, gut
wrenching human rejection and
having his ability to act at
least in that powerful,
miraculous way, severely limited
by that environment.
Our source makes that brilliant
comparison.
Superman doesn't need anybody.
He gets his power from the sun.
He can take a bullet to the iron
smirk.
The people of Earth can't add to
or take away from his strength.
Yeah, he's totally
self-contained.
Exactly.
Jesus isn't like that.
And that vulnerability, that
apparent susceptibility to the
environment, is what makes him
so heartbreakingly human, as the
author puts it, so utterly
within our grasp of
understanding somehow.
Yeah, you can almost feel the
sting of that rejection.
You can.
He walks into rooms wide open,
ready to give everything.
But this kind of shows us he's
also profoundly affected by the
atmosphere, susceptible to the
collective disbelief, the
cynicism, the closed minds and
hearts around him.
His power, unlike Superman's
raw, independent force, is shown
here to be fundamentally
relational.
Relational dependent on
connection.
In some essential way, yes.
And that directly challenges the
common idea of divine
omnipotence as this totally
independent, internal, always on
force that just bulldozes
through reality.
It introduces a kind of
dependence.
Not dependence born of weakness,
maybe, but dependence based on
the need for connection, for
receptivity from the very people
he encounters.
It paints a picture of a God who
chooses, perhaps, to work with
creation interactively, not just
over it unilaterally.
Which leads back to that phrase
you mentioned, spiritual
physics.
Exactly this concept of
vulnerability, this apparent
dependence on the environment,
on the receptivity of others, it
leads to this fascinating
insight our source calls
spiritual physics.
OK, unpack that a bit more.
The core idea is that the room
itself made him powerless, that
the faithless air choked the
miracles like oxygen sucked out
of a flame.
The author is careful to say
this isn't Jesus being arrogant
or punishing them.
Right, not withholding power out
of spite.
No.
Instead, it's presented as a
fundamental principle, a kind of
spiritual physics governing how
divine power actually interacts
with human reality.
So like a law of nature, but
spiritual.
Sort of.
The perspective suggests that
divine power, especially when
it's interacting with us, flows
only where faith breathes life
into it.
Without belief, without that
receptive medium, that openness,
there is no circuit.
Without that faith, there is no
oxygen.
It implies this fundamental,
almost natural law for how
spiritual power operates in the
world.
It needs a conductive medium.
It requires a connecting
current, a living atmosphere to
work within.
So God's power isn't just
imposed on us.
Not necessarily, or at least not
always.
This view suggests it often
works with us or through our
active participation, our
openness or receptivity.
Think about electricity again.
The power plant generates vast
amounts of energy, right?
But without the wires, the
switches, the whole circuit
connecting it to your lamp.
The light bulb stays dark.
The potential is there, but the
conditions for its manifestation
aren't met.
OK.
That makes sense.
Or sound.
My voice has potential sound,
but it needs air to travel.
A microphone needs power to
capture it.
Speakers need a current to
amplify it.
Without the right medium, the
right connections, the sound
doesn't reach you effectively.
Got it.
So it really shifts the
perception of Jesus's power.
Completely from this internal
always on switch to something
that requires or at least
invites external participation.
And that makes him, in a really
profound way, dependent on the
very people he came to serve.
Which is humbling, isn't?
It yeah, really humbling.
That the Son of God felt the
sting of being dismissed by the
people who should have known him
best, and that their collective
rejection, their lack of faith,
literally impacted his capacity
to act to bring healing in that
place.
It is heartbreakingly,
powerfully human.
And yet, OK, this incident shows
his vulnerability, his
powerlessness in that specific
situation, but it also,
paradoxically, maybe shows
incredible resilience.
Absolutely.
That's a crucial part of the
story.
He wasn't fragile, even though
he was made, in a sense,
powerless there he was
profoundly resilient.
So, well, he didn't stay and beg
them to believe, right?
He didn't try to force miracles
into a.
Dead room?
No.
He recognized the situation.
Exactly.
He simply walked away, and the
source emphasizes not.
Because he was offended,
although maybe he was, but
fundamentally because there was
literally nothing to work with.
He didn't just crumble under
that rejection.
He adapted.
He redirected his energy.
And that raises a really
important point about the wisdom
in that resilience.
Yeah.
It's not about giving up easily
when things get tough or running
away from any challenge.
It seems to be about recognizing
where effort is actually futile
because the fundamental
conditions aren't there.
That lack of receptivity was
total.
The soil was barren, as the
source says.
Precisely.
Faith is the field where
miracles grow.
In Nazareth, the soil was
barren.
This wasn't Jesus deciding to
withhold power as punishment.
It was, as the Source puts it,
Jesus finding himself in a room
where his power simply cannot
manifest because the necessary
conditions just weren't met.
That's an act of profound
spiritual discernment, wouldn't
you say?
Yeah, reading the room,
spiritually speaking.
Exactly.
And the few healings he did
manage, they become evidence of
this.
There were those tiny sparks in
an atmosphere that killed the
flame.
So leaving wasn't weakness, it
was a strategic withdrawal, a
redirection of his energy, his
presence, to places where it
could be effective.
Instead of just banging his head
against a brick wall.
Right.
It speaks to this deep
understanding of maybe spiritual
ecology.
You can't force growth in barren
soil.
Sometimes the wisest, most
powerful thing you can do is
recognize when an environment is
simply not conducive to your
purpose and move to one that is.
It's about being wise with your
energy, even divine energy.
That's a really powerful
contrast because Nazareth was
barren, choked by disbelief.
But other places they burst with
healing, with activity.
Where faith lived, where the
room breathe oxygen, power
erupted.
And this brings us to another
fascinating point from our
source, the role of the
disciples.
Oh yeah, yes, often just seen as
students.
Right, but this source presents
them in a much more dynamic
light.
Not just passive followers, but
as his batteries, his Co
creators.
Co creators.
Wow.
Yeah, the idea is that their
belief, their receptivity, their
active participation, it
actually amplified his mission.
That's a pretty radical idea,
isn't it?
Shared power.
It feels like it.
It really does reshape our
understanding of divine power.
It's just it's not something
just solely possessed and kind
of hoarded by God acting
unilaterally from above, right?
But maybe something actively
multiplied, shared, even enabled
through human cooperation and
receptivity, the source says.
He poured his power into them,
giving them authority to heal,
to cast out demons, to preach
the Kingdom of God.
He never hoarded divinity, he
multiplied it.
He multiplied it, yeah.
This isn't just delegation like
a CEO handing tasks down, it
feels more like a genuine Co
creative partnership where the
disciples faith, their
willingness, their openness
becomes an essential part of the
circuit, allows the power to
flow more strongly maybe.
Can you think of other examples?
Well, think about the story of
the paralytic man lower through
the roof.
Remember that one in Mark's
Gospel?
Yeah, the four friends.
Exactly, Mark says.
It wasn't just the paralyzed
man's faith, but when Jesus saw
their faith, the faith of his
friends who went to such extreme
lengths that he acted and healed
him.
Right.
Their collective faith.
Or Peter trying to walk on water
in Matthew.
For a moment, his faith connects
him to Jesus's power, enables
him to do the impossible until
doubt creeps in and the
connection breaks.
OK, yeah.
So this implies that our
collective belief, our shared
intention, the communal
atmosphere we create, they can
literally amplify or hinder the
good we want to see happen in
our own lives, our communities,
maybe even bigger societal
shifts.
So what does that mean for us
then?
To be Co creators or batteries.
Well, it's a huge question,
isn't it?
It suggests that our spiritual
environment that when we
cultivate in our active
participation in it can quite
literally enable or disable the
flow of, well, call it grace,
possibility, transformative
power, positive energy, whatever
language works for you, it puts
a lot more agency in our court.
Yeah, it really does.
And Speaking of preparation for
all this, pop culture often
gives this impression, right?
That Jesus just kind of burst
onto the scene at age 30, like
flipping a switch.
OK, miracle time.
Yeah, the hidden years are often
treated like a blank slate.
Exactly.
But our source really pushes
back against that.
It brings in this vital insight.
The 30 hidden years of his life
matter here to those decades,
almost his entire life up to
that point, spent supposedly
studying, praying, mastering
humility, living quietly.
They weren't just empty time.
They were formative.
Absolutely.
What's really fascinating is
seeing those 30 years not just
as a waiting period, like a
pause before the main event, but
as essential training for this
vulnerability, training for the
relational way his power work.
Training for vulnerability,
That's interesting.
Wasn't it?
It wasn't about, you know,
bulking up spiritual muscles or
acquiring brute divine force.
It seems it was more about
preparing for this nuanced,
interactive way of being
powerful, a way that required
connection and receptivity from
others.
So what would that training look
like?
Well, imagine the depth of
humility you'd learn living
quietly for decades.
The empathy gained from working
a trade, being part of a small
community, observing human
nature up close, participating
in synagogue life not as the
main event but just as a member.
Plus, presumably deep prayer
study spiritual practice.
He wasn't just building internal
power then.
It seems he was also honing his
capacity for relational
connection, for reading the
spiritual atmosphere of a room,
perhaps for understanding the
human heart.
The source notes that even by
the time of the wedding at Cana,
where he performs his first
sign, he was seen as a rabbi.
With thority.
He had presents.
Yet even then, back in Nazareth,
they saw only Joseph's boy.
Familiarity blinded them again.
Exactly, they're familiarity
blinded them to the man in front
of them.
It just reinforces how powerful
our prior perceptions are.
Fixed ideas about people can be.
They can literally block us from
seeing who someone has become.
The transformation that's
happened, regardless of the
evidence right in front of us,
it really underscores that
point.
Again, faith isn't a moral test
like earning points to deserve a
miracle.
It's intrinsically the medium
through which God's power lives.
The medium, the atmosphere, the
oxygen.
Exactly.
And in Nazareth there was no
faith, only cynicism.
And so the potential for
miracles just died in their
tracks.
It's like trying to send an
electrical current through a
completely severed wire, or
trying to teach something
profound to someone whose mind
is slammed shut.
Without the right medium,
without that spark of openness,
the light just can't turn on.
And again, it wasn't him
choosing to hold back.
It seems it was Jesus finding
himself in a situation in a room
where his power simply cannot
manifest because of the very
nature of that power which needs
that relational connection, that
receptive faith.
Those few healings, they really
were just tiny sparks in an
atmosphere that killed the OK.
So after digging into Nazareth,
into this unexpected limitation,
this vulnerability, what does
this all mean for us, sitting
here, listening now in our own
lives?
With the So what question?
Yeah.
I mean, if this kind of
spiritual limitation, this
environmental effect could
happen to him, the Messiah, the
Son of God, well, how much more
to us, right?
Right.
If collective disbelief,
cynicism, just a negative
atmosphere could hobble him in
that way, how can we expect to
thrive when we surround
ourselves with people and
environments that drain our
spirit and suffocate our
potential?
That really brings it home,
doesn't it?
Yeah.
It moves this ancient story out
of the history books and makes
it a powerful, immediate warning
for our own lives.
A.
Warning.
Yeah, I think so.
The Nazareth scene isn't just a
sad story about rejection.
It's a profound lesson about the
ecosystem of our own lives, our
spiritual, emotional, even
creative ecosystems.
OK, it highlights this crucial
need when we often overlook to
be incredibly intentional about
the environments we choose to
spend time in, both physically
and, you know, spiritually or
emotionally.
Intentional better environments.
Yeah, if even Jesus, according
to these accounts, needed a
receptive, faith filled
atmosphere for his power to
really flow, then we too
absolutely need to stay close to
those who breathe faith into us.
Those people, those places,
those activities that keep the
current alive, that give the
Spirit or just positive energy,
possibility, creativity, room to
move.
Jesus needed that.
So do we.
Exactly.
Think about the rooms you walk
into every day.
Maybe it's your workplace.
Is the culture there one of
cynicism, negativity, or
collaboration and encouragement?
Good question.
What about your personal
relationships?
Do certain interactions leave
you feeling drained and
diminished, or energized and
seen your social circles?
Do conversations tend towards
gossip and complaint, or towards
shared hopes and mutual support?
Even the stuff we consume
online, maybe?
Absolutely.
Does scrolling leave you feeling
anxious and depleted or inspired
and connected?
Are these environments providing
the oxygen for your ideas, your
purpose, your well-being, your
unique spark, or they actively
draining your spirit, stifling
your potential?
It's not just about avoiding
negativity then.
No, it's more active than that.
It's about consciously seeking
out and cultivating
environments, physical spaces,
communities, relationships, even
internal mindsets that enable
your own power grid to function.
Environments where you can
receive and transmit positive
energy, purpose, creativity.
It's about tending the soil so
that your potential, your
miracles, whatever they might
be, actually have a chance to
grow.
Wow.
That is a powerful challenge.
And it makes this Nazareth scene
with all its raw honesty, it's
counterintuitive message, it
makes it feel like it should be
iconic.
You know, it really should.
It gives us this picture of a
Messiah who bleeds emotionally,
who can be rendered powerless in
the face of disbelief, who walks
away not in anger, maybe, but
just because the power grid is
dead.
It's a challenging image.
It is.
It's so much easier to paint him
as a glowing superhero, like our
source says.
Yeah, this distant figure of
effortless power.
It's much harder to face this
raw vulnerability, this profound
relational dependence.
But maybe, maybe it's and that
vulnerability that we find a
deeper, more resonant truth.
I think that's exactly right.
And what's truly fascinating
here is that counterintuitive
revelation that emerges.
The Gospels, by having the
courage to show us this moment,
to not airbrush out the
vulnerability and the
limitation, they actually reveal
a God whose power is not
primarily over us, but with us.
With us, yeah.
And paradoxically, that makes
him feel more divine, not less.
It transforms our understanding
of divinity itself away from
abstract, distant, unilateral
omnipotence towards a
relational, interactive
presence, one that invites our
participation rather than just
demanding our submission.
It deepens the mystery, but it
also strengthens the potential
for real connection.
And the author of that
reflection?
Their motivation wasn't
necessarily to preach or to
deconstruct just for kicks.
It was simply, as they put it,
to share the Jesus I've been
meeting.
The Jesus who experienced
Nazareth.
Exactly.
The one who walked into that
synagogue, ready to give, ready
to heal, and found the air
sucked out of the room.
The one whose power flickered
and died in the face of
disbelief, and who still
resiliently kept going to find
where the oxygen remained.
It's a powerful redefinition of
strength, isn't it?
Not his limitless force, but his
persistent relational engagement
even in vulnerability.
So boiling it all down, the
ultimate take away from this
deep dive seems to be this
really profound realization.
If even the Son of God, the
Messiah, needed faith, that
receptive atmosphere to breathe
life into his power, then faith
isn't just, you know, an
internal belief system.
It's not just a mental
agreement.
More fundamental.
Yeah, it's the power grid
itself.
It's the conduit, the
atmosphere, the oxygen, the very
condition that makes certain
kinds of divine action, or maybe
even just profound positive
change possible.
And maybe, maybe that's the real
miracle.
Here what do you mean?
Not just the flashy,
extraordinary events, the
healings, The Walking on water,
whatever, but the very condition
of possibility that's created by
belief, by that reciprocal
connection between the divine
and the human, by our openness.
It highlights the incredible,
maybe often underestimated,
power of human faith, of our
collective receptivity, our
openness, our trust in actually
enabling the Divine, or just
enabling profound good to
manifest in our world.
Wow, what a shift in
understanding that is.
Moving from that distant,
untouchable God figure to
someone deeply human,
vulnerable, profoundly
relational, whose power is so
intricately linked to the
presence of faith, to that
connection.
It changes everything about how
you might think about your own
role in things, doesn't it?
It really does.
It puts a lot more agency and
maybe responsibility squarely
back on us, too, on the
environments we create, the
faith we cultivate, the
connections we foster.
Indeed.
And maybe, just maybe, he's
still walking into rooms today,
today, looking for oxygen.
So the question maybe to leave
you, the listener with to just
Mull over after this deep dive
is what kind of oxygen are you
cultivating in your own life and
your close relationships, in
your communities, in the spaces
you inhabit?
And what transformative
possibilities might open up for
you, for others, when faith in
that broad sense of receptivity,
trust, openness, hope, When
that's allowed to truly breathe.